FELICIA MARTINEZ: We're angry.
We're very angry.
And we want justice
for our kids.
And for this to be
let out without us
even being seen first?
We're the parents that
lost our children.
We're supposed to
do this together
first, not for the world.
We're suffering, and I know
the world is suffering, too,
but these were our babies, our
babies that were taken from us.
So to the person that
leaked it, screw you.
Screw you, and that's coming
from me, Felicia Martinez,
from all of us.
Screw you.
ANGEL GARZA: Who in the hell
do these people think they are?
I don't care if you're a
DA, you're a spokesperson,
you're a Councilman,
you're a Senator.
Who do you think you are to
release footage like that
of our children who can't
even speak for themselves,
but you want to go ahead
and air their final moments
to the entire world?
What makes you think that's OK?
The least you can do is have
some freaking decency for us.
That is unacceptable.
NIKKI CROSS: We've been asking
DA for this video for a while,
and she refused
to let us see it.
So once again, the world got
to see it before us, just
like the day of the
shooting when Governor
Abbott announced to you all
that our children were dead,
and we had no idea.
So it's like reliving
that day all over again.
And I'm sick of it.
I'm tired of it, so tired.